- What's up Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Charmichael.
My one word is "believe" and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve all
of the world's major problems.
And today I'm excited because I'm
launching a new series, we're
kickstarting a new series, that's a pun.
We'll see how it works
and if you guys like it.
I'm calling it The Best of Kickstarter
where I look at three different campaigns
that are currently happening
right now on Kickstarter.
Show some of their videos,
and I'd love to know
what do you think of them?
Would you support them?
Do you enjoy them?
And I'd love to hear from you below
if you want this series to continue,
and I'll keep on promoting some different
entrepreneurs with some innovative
products on Kickstarter.
Up first is Arsenal which dubs itself
as the intelligent camera assistant,
and promises to "unlock the potential
"of your DSLR or your mirrorless camera
"and capture amazing
images in any conditions."
- [Narrator] Let's talk about
taking the perfect photo.
First, compose the shot,
check the histogram,
adjust the exposure,
focus on your subject.
Compute the hyperfocal distance
to keep everything sharp,
enable bracketing to
get more dynamic range.
Add a neutral density
filter, update the exposure,
and then take the shot.
We built a better way.
- Today's DSLR mirrorless cameras
have amazing optics and sensors,
but they do very little to actually
help you take a good photo.
Finding the right settings involves
a series of complex
techniques and formulas.
As an engineer with a background
in artificial intelligence,
I knew I could build a tool
to simplify the process.
I wanted something that would
let me focus on the composition,
but would handle the details for me.
So I created Arsenal, the world's first
AI photography assistant.
With one tap Arsenal finds settings
to take the best photo possible.
Arsenal's AI searches thousands of images
in its database to suggest good settings.
Next, it fine tunes the suggestions
by analyzing 18 different factors.
Arsenal uses state of
the art machine learning
to help you take a great
photo in any condition.
(upbeat music)
Many of the memorable shots you see today
are captured by combining
multiple exposures
through a labor intensive
process called photo stacking.
With Arsenal you can do this in seconds.
Capture all the details in scenes
with high dynamic range, get
everything in sharp focus,
and create long exposures
without buying expensive filters.
Using these advanced techniques,
Arsenal will let you go
beyond the limitations
of your camera's sensor or lens.
For times when you want complete control,
you can wirelessly adjust manual settings,
see a live preview,
and trigger the shutter
all from up to 100 feet away.
Arsenal also improves the experience
of reviewing photos in the field.
You can flip through the
photos on your camera,
zoom in to check out
details at full resolution,
then share your favorite
photos right from your phone.
And finally, Arsenal makes it easy
to capture stunning time lapses.
It automatically adjusts the exposure
and changing light, giving you
a smooth day to night transition.
You can even watch a high def preview
of your time lapse while it's being taken.
Whether you're a pro
who has already mastered
manual shooting, or you
just bought your first DSLR,
Arsenal can help you take your photography
to the next level.
So before you replace your gear,
try upgrading your technique with Arsenal.
Arsenal is already being
tested in the field.
Now I need your help
to ramp up production.
By supporting our campaign today,
you can be one of the
first to get Arsenal.
We've got exclusive rewards
for our early backers,
and some awesome stretch
goals in the works.
I'm really excited about the photos
I've been getting with Arsenal.
I can't wait to share it with you
and see all the amazing
photos you'll create.
- Alright, that's Arsenal.
Up next is Bolt Drones which promises to
introduce a whole new flight experience
in innovative and versatile
First Person View drone
at a radical new price.
Let's check it out.
- [Narrator] Piloting drones
is a relatively new activity
that most people are starting to explore.
We wanted to design a
drone that introduced
as many people as possible
to the First Person View
drone experience without
breaking the bank.
Introducing a whole new flight experience.
The Bolt is an innovative and versatile
First Person View drone
available at a radical price.
It's a complete, ready to
fly out of the box solution
that's easy and safe to pilot.
The drone for everyone.
There are three ways to fly.
First, for beginners, to start flying,
simply turn on the drown
and turn on the controller.
The two will sync up and
pair, and you can take off.
The drone features altitude stabilization
and a beginner's mode that makes
picking up the basics a breeze.
Learn how to safely and confidently
maneuver and control your drone.
Next, for those ready to
expand their horizons,
attach the screen to the controller
and start piloting the drone further away.
Simply turn on the drone and the screen.
The camera on the drone
will automatically sync
and broadcast a live,
high definition feed.
Mount the screen on the
controller and you're ready to go.
Finally, for those ready for the full
First Person View experience,
swap the screen to the goggles
and prepare for a whole
new flight experience.
Immerse yourself into the
world of FPV piloting,
and cruise around high in the sky.
Or try your hand at FPV drone racing
and experience the incredible excitement
from every twist and turn.
Drone racing is a new and exciting sport
that is quickly growing around the world.
Using FPV goggles,
pilots race their drones
around courses to compete
for the fastest times.
It is truly the sport of the future.
The Bolt can be used to
experience drone racing
at a fraction of the current price.
It's an exciting virtual
reality flying experience.
The Bolt drone was designed
and tested in Los Angeles
by a team of expert product designers,
aerospace engineers,
and drone enthusiasts.
It's built on a carbon fiber frame
that offers unmatched
performance and durability.
The HD camera provides crystal
clear video and photos.
And the battery easily slides in and out
for quick swapping.
The drone design is modular
so that individual parts
can be replaced.
The result is a highly maneuverable
and lightweight and aerodynamic drone.
The bolt features a unique and innovative
FPV viewing system that
allows seamless transition
from traditional viewing on the controller
to FPV viewing using goggles.
We're excited to offer the
Bolt drone at a radical price.
Traditionally, consumers
purchase their drones
at a high price point since importers,
wholesalers and retailers mark up
the price of a drone up to 500%.
By cutting out the middleman, we are able
to sell directly to you
and pass on the savings.
The Bolt drone was designed to introduce
as many people as possible
to First Person View
piloting and racing
without breaking the bank.
With our finished prototypes
ready for production,
we're here on Kickstarter to raise
the money we need for our first batch.
With bolt drones, we want
to make First Person View
piloting and racing
accessible to everyone.
With your support, this could be
the start of something big.
Thanks for watching.
- Alright that's Bolt Drones, and last,
but not least, we'll
give it up for FYB London
which dubs itself to be "the
world's smartest handbag."
I think Nina will like this one.
Let's check it out.
(upbeat music)
- Hello?
- [Caller] I'm interested in
getting a handbag like yours.
Can you tell me more about it?
- [Narrator] A dead
phone is the perfect way
to ruin a good day, but
with the Smart Handbag
you'll never have to
worry about that again.
Simply drop your phone
into the charging pocket
and keep your phone up and running
for as along as you are.
No more searching at length for
important items in your bag.
With this handbag,
everything has its place,
ready for a quick retrieval when needed.
Whether at work, or traveling,
or anywhere in between,
our London Smart Handbag
keeps your items organized and safe.
To protect your belongings from theft,
each handbag unlocks only
to your unique fingerprint
or access via the Bluetooth app.
Our Smart Bag is also
equipped with RFID protected
card holders to keep your credit card
and other sensitive information safe.
And the Bluetooth connectivity feature
automatically notifies your phone
if your bag leaves your side.
But we know none of these
features matter much
if the handbag isn't beautiful.
Rest assured, we spent several months
diligently working not only on
all of the amazing smart features,
but on the eye catching,
luxurious leather classic style.
This bag is the ultimate
smart fashion accessory.
- So those are the three
Kickstarter campaigns
I wanted to highlight.
All the links are down below,
I'd love to know what do you guys think?
Did you like the camera assistant?
Did you like the Bolt drones?
Or did you like the Smart Handbag?
If you were going to buy one, which one
would be your favorite.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Also, this is again a test
of a new potential series.
Do you want this Best of Kickstarter idea
to continue next month or not?
Let me know down in the comments,
we'll see what you have to say.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.